hi sisters James Charles here with et
live instead we're gonna be talking
about all things in the sisterhood do
you have a business icon ah probably
Kris Jenner oh so we can leave I feel
like so many people love to bash on them
for just being like oh so talentless but
that woman has single-handedly turned
her entire family into a billion-dollar
Empire she's a legend
have you met Kris I have I have her
phone number she's the sweetest I met
her so many times I'm close with her and
her entire family which is amazing what
kind of facts are you sending with Kris
Jenner
not many I try not to bother her because
I know she's very busy but she's just
the absolute Squealer she's always been
very very supportive of me and my career
she's always said if I need anything to
reach out to her so what would you reach
out to her about business stuff cuz
you're now build I'd be like my sister
can you sign me as one of your next
daughters
well we know that of course you did that
amazing collab with Kylie yeah but
everyone loved what is that like when
you see that message from Kylie Jenner
that she wants to collab with you well
it was so cool I mean Kylie is she's
very close to my age she's working super
hard just think I am so it was just a
really cool opportunity to work with
someone who is has a very similar
mindset to the way that I do so it was a
really amazing experience and I
definitely look forward to it again she
was so chill she was super it just felt
like I was hanging out with a best
friend for 10 years she was it was an
amazing experience and we've already
been talking about working on other
stuff in the future so it'll be another
video yeah it was just really really
amazing she was so sweet and it was just
really amazing to see somebody else in
the space working really hard and just
making it at a young age she's a huge
inspiration to me and it's just been I
definitely had a similar experience to
her in the sense that people just love
to tell you down and bash you and stuff
it she she's a great role model people
tearing you down bashing you what have
you learned about how to move forward
when that does not care like literally
just keep scrolling I feel like if
there's somebody gonna if there's
somebody that's like wasting their own
time to sit there and like write a
comment last time that they could have
been working on themselves or like
building their own brand so like Hello
it's not worth that I used like I said I
used to get very very funded over that's
up and I used to always clap back and
snap and occasionally I still of course
well every once in a while but I believe
it's important to defend yourself and to
really stand up for what you believe in
and I just really tried to avoid those
people because if they're wasting their
own time on that it says a lot more
about them than it does about you we
loved how Shawn Mendes DM Jew so what's
your reaction like would you get back to
you
it was amazing I've looked up to him for
a very very long time since he was huge
I'm fine I think he's literally the
cutest that was a really unfortunate
moment on Twitter with all the fans and
stuff but I'm really just thankful that
he cleared it up and allowed me to post
the screenshot so we could like move on
and stuff and not have any beef because
I would have been have you guys talked
at all since then we do him back and
forth a few times no flirting
unfortunately for me but he's super
super sweet and I'm really thankful that
he cleared it out but I loved that he
did that because not every celebrity
would take the time to be like yo we're
good yeah yeah yeah I was I was shocked
that idea and I was very excited
[Music]